bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition de check up votre
magazine santé bien-être au programme ce
mois ci un nouveau goûté au centre
socioculturel de trappes sur le thème de
la ménopause
nous irons également à l'hôpital de
pédiatrie de bullion nous y avons
rencontré deux jeunes adolescents lors
d'un atelier diététique
nous terminerons enfin par du sport du
sport adapté aux personnes âgées de 50
ans et plus le karaté santé mais tout
d'abord direction saint germain en laye
un nouveau centre unique en france vient
d'être inauguré c'est l'institut en
santé génésique
depuis le début du mois de janvier une
vingtaine de bénévoles y accueille des
femmes victimes de violences elles
peuvent y être amenées par des médecins
ou tout simplement venir d'elle-même en
nous poussant la porte des
professionnels ont été formés et
coordonnée pour mieux leur venir en aide
claire conviés pour les images les
locaux de l'institut en santé génésique
ont été inauguré il ya quelques jours
des locaux prêts à accueillir les femmes
victimes de toutes les violences
physiques morales ou encore économiques
et les professionnels à leur écoute
médecins infirmières psychologues
assistantes sociales et juristes tous
bénévoles sont réunis sur le site et
travaillent ensemble pour aider ces
femmes on s'est très vite rendu compte
qu'en fait les femmes en fête souffrait
en silence
et quand elle reprenait la parole c'est
un nouvel espoir est elle retombée dans
le silence pourquoi parce que le
parcours était morcelée et pas pérenne
et nous nous engageons dans cette
pérennité
puisque nous faisons non seulement une
prise en charge une orientation et un
suivi et ça c'est très important donc on
demande à la femme qu'elle nous autorise
en fait à être contactés que l'on puisse
savoir ce qu'elle devient et pour donner
un coup de projecteur sur ce premier
centre consacré la prise en charge des
femmes victimes de violences florence
foresti a accepté d'être la marraine
grâce à florence nous n'avons jamais
baissé les bras
tout simplement parce que lorsque nous
sommes allés l'a rencontré il ya
maintenant plus d'un
une première fois elle nous a dit oui on
voit très bien que ce sont des sujets
très complexes et que moi je veux sortir
aussi de la victimisation des femmes
c'est pour petites choses qui peuvent
pas se défendre c'est pas ça c'est
beaucoup plus complexe comme on l'a vu
aujourd'hui parce qu'une femme c'est
aussi une mère parce qu'une femme elle
travaille ou pas parce qu'une femme elle
peut encore subir une domination
économique sein de son couple donc les
violences faites aux femmes c'est
beaucoup plus qu'une gifle en fin de
repas ce qui est déjà absolument
intolérable mais ça peut être beaucoup
plus subtil que ça et plus et subtile
tue c'est difficile de leur venir en
aide
dans ce domaine les yvelines n'ont rien
à envier aux autres départements
les cas de violences mortelles contre
les familles sont parmi les plus
nombreux
c'est le cinquième département le plus
touché en france depuis son ouverture le
6 janvier 2014
l'institut en santé génésique a déjà
accueilli plus d'une trentaine de femmes
ça nous a surpris
on aurait préféré en avoir moins à
quelque part parce que on se serait dit
que l'on s'est trompé et en fait on ne
s'est pas trompé on a constaté que à
peine cette porte ouverte on n'arrive
même plus à tenir nos permanences elles
viennent quand elles peuvent le soir
après le travail en allant chercher le
pain par exemple voilà et on est très
très frappé par la précarité de ces
femmes qui effectivement s'inscrivent
dans quelque chose d'extrêmement
douloureux c'est une détresse
effectivement psychologique mais est
extrêmement
économique puisqu'elle arrive
effectivement sans ressources
situé dans l'enceinte du centre
hospitalier intercommunal de poissy
saint germain en laye le centre financé
en partie par des dons privés n'a
bénéficié pour le moment d'aucune aide
de l'état
la marraine florence foresti et lancé
une campagne d'appel aux dons
un geste qui permettrait de gagner une
rencontre avec l'humoriste à l'occasion
de son prochain spectacle au théâtre du
châtelet cet automne
on reste sur des problématiques liées
aux femmes puisque nous parlons à
présent de ménopause
un thème abordé par le dr jacques ce
galles lors de son dernier goûter santé
attrape les femmes rencontrées ce jour
là il était très attentive un reportage
réalisé avec romain gabette elodie
moines
les interventions du docteur jacques
galaup centre socioculturel des
merisiers attrape connaissent toujours
un franc succès et traitent de sujets
très différents
au programme ce jour là la santé des
femmes de la puberté à la ménopause la
ménopause n'est pas une maladie c'est un
phénomène naturel qui arrive à toutes
les femmes elle se déclare par l'arrêt
des menstruations les ovaires arrête de
fabriquer les hormones de la
reproduction les oestrogènes et la
progestérone ce qui peut entraîner
certaines complications le peuvent à 7
le à ce moment ressentir des troubles
tels que qui peuvent être très
désagréable comme des bouffées de
chaleur comme de la sécheresse vaginale
comme des troubles de la tension
artérielle
il y à tout ce qui se passe aussi de
façon plus souterraine au niveau du
métabolisme des os qui se raréfie lequel
la trame osseuse est moins solide ce qui
fait qu'on a ce qu'on appelle le
l'ostéoporose c'est pas constant une
femme sur deux n'a aucun trouble à la
ménopause à l'aide de schémas et des
changes le docteur ce gala porte des
informations précieuses pour les
personnes présentes
il explique bien parce qu'il ya des
docteurs et qui nous explique pas bien
des fois il ya des choses qu'on connaît
pas mais là explique bien un pour une
pose des questions on a des bonnes
réponses
la ménopause intervient chez les femmes
autour de la cinquantaine le docteur
jacques seguin elle rappelle
l'importance d'être suivi par un médecin
c'est une période où il faut en plus des
examens habituels que sont la
mammographie bien entendu les frottis
l'examen gynécologique
il faut pendant les deux ou trois
premières années de la ménopause ou
moins une fois par an faire
examens plus approfondis interrogés les
femmes sur comment elles se sentent en
sachant que c'est aussi sur le plan
psychologique une période fragile pour
prévenir les risques d'ostéoporose il
faut passer des examens radiologiques
appelé ostéodensitométrie il est
recommandé de manger davantage de
l'étagé de poids sont dégoûtés santé du
docteur jacques seguin elle se déroule
attrape une fois par mois
à bullion l'hôpital de pédiatrie
accueille une centaine d'enfants malades
une maison d'éducation thérapeutique
vient d'y ouvrir c'est là que nous avons
rencontré deux jeunes adolescents lors
d'un atelier diététique patrick jacques
de dixmude pour les images à l'hôpital
pédiatrique de bullion mohamed amine
savoure déjà le menu qu'il a préparé
avec ses camarades
un menu qu'ils ont choisi ensemble et
qu'ils ont cuisiné maison lors d'un
séjour de trois mois minimum ses enfants
obèses reprennent goût au sport et lors
de cet atelier
ils reviennent sur les fondamentaux d'un
repas équilibré on apprend à savoir
manger les 38 et les caisses qu'il doit
mettre par exemple dans d'autres pas
comme les féculents légumes ça nous
apprend qu on peut se faire plaisir en
mangeant ce qu'on veut qu'il suffit
juste d'équilibrer quoi et c'est ça que
j'aime bien qu'on a choisi ensemble
qu'est ce qu'on voulait faire et tout et
qu'on puisse se faire plaisir tout en
mangeant normalement équilibré cet
atelier diététique fait partie des
nombreux soins proposés au sein de la
maison d'éducation thérapeutique une
maison inauguré il ya un peu moins d'un
an est financé en grande partie par le
ministère de la santé pour les enfants
c'est en quelque sorte une zone
intermédiaire entre l'hôpital et la
maison
l'idée c'est effectivement d'éduquer les
parents et enfants sur les soins sur les
gestes de manière à ce que l'on favorise
alors soit le retour à domicile soit des
séjours
des permissions qui permettent à
l'enfant de se réintégrer de reprendre
un peu une vie dans son milieu social
familial avec ses copains etc
l'éducation thérapeutique a la
particularité de s'orienter vraiment sur
le patient dans son environnement socio
familiale et d'intégrer donc toutes ses
composantes et de faire vraiment une
éducation personnalisés à la sortie de
cette maison l'objectif est donc de
rendre l'enfant et ses parents les plus
autonome possible dans la gestion de la
maladie pour la plupart des patients il
s'agit de pathologies lourdes telles que
des maladies chroniques des maladies
rares des cancers ou encore des grands
brûlés
l'hôpital de bullion accueille environ
130 enfants
c'est une activité physique idéal pour
les articulations
le système cardiovasculaire ou encore
les troubles du vieillissement
le karaté santé proposé pour la deuxième
saison à bois d'arcy ces disciplines
permet aux seniors de pratiquer un sport
de combat adaptés à leur âge un
reportage réalisé avec elodie moines et
patrick jacq 10 mai la séance démarre
avec un échauffement est toujours en
douceur ses élèves de 50 ans et plus
pratique un caracter adaptés à leur âge
le karaté santé une discipline proposée
à bois d'arcy pour la deuxième année
consécutive c'est long à démarrer parce
que les gens les gens qui ont 60 ans si
vous voulez dire au revoir je vais faire
du karaté
ohlala
je cassais ceci cela alors que c'est pas
du tout ça au contraire beaucoup
d'assouplissement et d'étirements sont
au programme l'objectif est de retrouver
une certaine souplesse du dynamisme mais
pas seulement
ce qu'on apprend aussi ces deux au gens
de se sortir d'une situation délicate il
est bon aussi une prise demain s'ils
sont reprendre leur sac comme si vous
voulez ddd des petites choses comme ça
qui leur permet si vous voulez de se
sécuriser 216 sentir un peu plus en
confiance
parmi les adeptes ceux qui ont déjà
pratiqué le karaté est un jeune comme
xavier déjà 30 ans de pratique derrière
lui et aujourd'hui grâce au karaté santé
ils se concentrent moins sur le combat
mais plus sur l'aspect technique
on s'entraîne surtout à notre rythme
parce que c'est vrai que il ya la
problématique du cardio vasculaires donc
on peut pas se permettre non plus
d'avoir une activité trop intense ce qui
nous intéresse nous c'est surtout
d'avoir une activité complète de faire
du sport et puis je serai aussi de se
distraire que de faire travailler un
petit peu sa tête et ses neurones
puisqu'il ya quand même beaucoup de
techniques à apprendre d'autres en
revanche sont totalement débutant dans
la discipline
c'est le cas de yannick en un peu plus
d'un an il a passé sa ceinture verte et
compte bien accéder au graal la ceinture
noire image de marque était un peu ce
qu'il bourrin donc je me suis méfié
ainsi nommée femme nature donc quand on
va présenter les choses je dis bon qui
s'allonge eux je fais un jv moi j'aime
bien le sport les moues trois semaines
un mois les profs ils m'ont posé
question vous gagnez ce que ça te
convient est ce que tu veux qu'on
améliore le show où tu vas arrêter quoi
bein suprenant donc je suis parti appuie
à partir à fond quoi non c'est une
passion
c'est la fin de ce nouveau numéro deux
check up avant de nous quitter vous le
savez c'est le moment de votre agenda le
vendredi 28 mars ce sera la journée
nationale du sommeil
à cette occasion l'association équilibre
énergie de montigny le bretonneux
organise une conférence suivie d'un
atelier gratuit sur les mécanismes du
sommeil le 11 avril à versailles une
collecte mobile de don du sang est
organisée ce sera de 14h30 à 19h frais
de l'hôtel de ville et de la gare rive
gauche c'est terminé merci de votre
attention je vous donne rendez-vous dans
un mois
d'ici là portez vous bien